[Music]
okay okay
hello I'm Dennis boorish Grandmaster
residence
this is viewers Choice hello everyone
it's gonna be fun hopefully so let's see
Alan James this game efore b-59 f3 f6
now I'm not a big fan of f6 because it's
not a good move knight c6 is preferred
but if you want to draw the game just
play Knight f6 and you'll draw but okay
f6 which is not good
anyone helped me how to punish f6
quickly
I mean Knight takes e5 is one option
because takes and g6 is not a good idea
because of Queen e5 and the rook will
drop and then white will have a
tremendous attack now d4 is fine though
he takes d4 Knight takes d4 Knight c6
Knight takes c6 well whenever you have a
great positional advantage it's not the
best idea to start exchanging it's
better to keep more material up so
Knight c3 would have been better or even
Bishop c4 immediately pointing out that
it's not a great idea to open up the a
to g8 diagonal so Knight takes c6 D
takes c6 takes takes and shockingly they
already in a reuleaux pass exchange
variation Bishop d3 there should be six
Castle Knight d7 b3 a5 Bishop b2 b3 was
a very good move this is actually very
well known from Berlin and games where
they developed the Bishop to b2 trying
to exert some pressure on this blockade
on f6 and g7 a5 Bishop b2 b5 Knight c3
another idea would be to stop the
expansion with a4 and also pointing out
that a5 will be a weakness in the
upcoming battle Knight c3 but developing
is never wrong if you can develop a
piece that's always good before 9 a 4 B
4 is a no-no because now the c5 squared
will be eternally week 9 day for night
c8 would be one ship d6 should be to c5
f4 and now black makes a terrible
mistake in place King g7
which is left unpunished if I would be
winning a piece takes half takes and the
bishop is suddenly trapped now f5 on the
other hand obviously e5 is the winner
but an f5 from a positional standpoint
is a very good move as it prepares the
onslaught but II 5 because with the f5
move black is preparing to push through
with a 5 so it's a very goodthe mattock
move in general but in this concrete
situation if I was just winning at 5
bishop f7 Bishop f3 and this was already
mentioned by the message of the white
player he does have a very nice
dominating position with white and this
is what you get when you start
developing all your pieces and
concentrate on the positional vices of
your position now white is basically
positionally winning even though he
missed the early win with e5 he has a
dominating bishop pair on f3 and b2 and
also a 5 is looming in the air
rook the eight missing e5 takes takes
and the rook was captured but even if
white wouldn't get this luxury of
getting an extra rookin that save would
be 8 how could we increase our
advantages in this position
it's fairly straightforward how wide
could play here any suggestions
v5 is an idea you know trying to open up
the position yeah rook e1 yeah
whenever we have an idea we don't have
to rush but executing it you don't have
to play e5 immediately and I'll show you
why if we play e5 now then he could take
take take rook e1 and the King could
move to f6 c5 is hanging and this is
still wonderful for white but if we play
with E one which is considered a
prophylactic move the e5 idea is
unstoppable there is no way he could
defend against it and he can't move the
King to f6 yet yeah
but then to see if Bishop e5 the c5
would be hanging yeah I mean black can
still fight but it's a pawn yeah so rook
d8 and after E 5 white wanna rook and
the game later on so you can send in
games to info at San Luis chess club org
I was it perfect
sorry ok so this game was sent by
Rebecca from Brazil and she asked if she
played a perfect game and the marshal
with black so let's flip the board gonna
be black b4 b5
should be fun a six very standard
Iranian loves it so it can be that bad
we should pay for Bishop e7 now I've
never seen Aronian play this so it might
be suspicious now it's not necessarily
bad it's just unusual I guess your idea
is to transpose back to this type of
exchange Spanish variation with this
Bishop e7 and this is a specific line in
the exchange and it would continue like
castles you can play f6 and if you like
more extravagant plays you can play
Bishop f6 and 97 let's say D 397 92 96
and this was played by a fantastic
Ukranian player Roman ushion and it's a
very interesting play but I don't like
that Bishop on f6 so no let's not do
this let's play f6 instead and then d3
Bishop g4 and act black has an okay
position so Bishop e7 castles Knight f6
and we're back on track everybody knows
this everybody loves this
maybe Geary doesn't like it but we love
the Spanish rook e1 b5 Bishop e3 Castle
c3 and d5 a position often dreaded by
white it's very exciting and interesting
but sadly it's been analyzed a lot and
many of the lines and in turn draws
edicts Knight takes Knight e5 takes
takes c6 now the old line was actually
Knight f6 played by Marshall against
capablanca it's a game well worth the
watch but c6 is obviously the main line
d4 Bishop d6 rook e1 Queen h4 g3 green a
three Queen f3 now Queen f3 is kind of a
rare move not a good move kind of
suspicious move what moves what usually
tries is either Bishop III and F for
example Bishop g4 then Queen d3 and beef
just before check made the Queen comes
to the rescue
it's a long long Tara tickle line with
fighting chances it's not over yet there
is still some life in this position also
this there's this line with Knight d2
Bishop d7 or Bishop g4 and it goes on
and on with many many complicated lines
Queen f3 is a little bit suspicious and
for a good reason
can anybody help me why Queen f3 is a
little bit suspect in this position
there's a simple reason why this move is
not so good
Bishop g4 but in general what what
sprint what's the principal problem with
Queen f3 it does defend the Kings side
but why lags something what is wipe
lagging in this position yeah I mean
Bishop g4 is coming but the question is
why is Queen f3 not a good move
what is the reason why it's not good
there are principled reasons why it's
not good yes the tempos yes the bishop
on c1 and b1 is undeveloped so it's just
natural it's wrong to move another piece
out while you're being on their attack
that's why Bishop easy or an ID 2 is
much better because what is in hurry to
catch up a development exactly so that's
why Queen f3 is not a great idea Bishop
g4 in g2 Queen h5 very good move when
you're playing the Marshall you're not
trying to exchange Queens you're trying
to play for the initiative 92 Bishop h3
Bishop h3 is an okay move but there's an
even stronger move here it's very yeah
yeah hook a e8 it's a very classical way
of playing and usually asking the
question where the Queen should go
should wait a little bit because Bishop
h3 just makes life easier a little bit
for white so rook e8 is better
also it hinders white from developing
more easily
for example if rook takes a one rook
takes I mean
rook takes a 8th route xc8 there's no
Knight e4 because of Bishop f3 and also
after Knight f1 rook e1 even Bishop f3
is getting annoying
I mean g4 is still there but it's
already looking very bad or rook e1 and
the position is near lost yeah so rookie
a e8 would have been better but Bishop
h3 is okay bishop d1 and again clean f5
is played which is fine but there's an
even stronger surprising move actually
that that could work in this position
it's black to move
sexually peculiar is situation because
white is not defending against the
threat of taking the G to Queen instead
attacks the Queen on h5 you have rue ke8
with the idea that's the idea of okay
but how how does it mean equality
take root
I'll play clean f1 Jake and it's a piece
up
so is rookie it's good or not
yes intermediate checks are important
and they went win us games and now why
just loses a queen
so in fact Rebecca you would have won
with luque eh immediately as white is
forced to part with material after rook
f1 just takes takes and takes more
material on f1 and basically why this
busted because the natural way of
defending in this position would be
either of on taking on eh yes or not
efore but that doesn't really work here
because Bishop takes g2 takes and Bishop
takes e4 so Queen f5 rukia y8 would be a
winning shot here though Queen f5 Queen
f3 rook f e8 also a good move although I
would prefer the a e8 move because
giving the option to your opponent to
take your pieces with check could turn
out to be a problem later on rook e8 94
but after Queen f3 Bishop battery f5 and
the game of chess is a tragedy of a
tempo while it is utterly lost because
he lacks this one move Bishop d2 now if
obviously white would be on move let's
say that just make the position viable
this would be a normal position but
already this is blundering the piece and
white is just losing this ship takes e4
can't get 7 b3 rook c8 rookie to Knight
f6 very good trying to exchange the
pieces when you're a piece up that's a
good idea
rook e1 takes takes takes okie eight
takes c4 give me 7
and white has two pawns but his King is
too passive so there's no real hope of
for survival c5 c7 and also c5 is not
good because you should try to build a
fortress why should be trying to hold
still and hope for the best
even though it's lost anyways because
Bishop III takes takes Bishop e6 and all
those pawns on c4 and a2 will just fall
c5 7f 4 king g6 King d5 King III a v g6
and slowly slowly black is winning h5
before very good pinpointing that
there's a weakness on b3 takes takes
takes and this is just winning so I just
resigned a good game but summing it up
if you're playing the marshal with white
you need to develop your pieces you
don't have the luxury to wait and just
defend your King because otherwise you
will be just one tempo short from the
back legs perspective always try to find
attacking moves which don't give extra
options for a wide let's say rook a e8
instead of rook F 8 because root K 8
doesn't give the option for whites to
give a check and in fact that was one of
the winning moves that you could have
played but all in all a good game yes
this is an interesting game car calm d5e
takes d5 well ii thik z5 is a little bit
timid and i know it's very popular these
days but e5 is the main move and also
the old main line played by everyone was
Knight c3 D takes Bishop f5 and 93 here
h4
ninety-seven here here
and this is basically the old to be a
position played in the Kramnik lako
match and also many many classical games
were played here but surprisingly it was
played by Tony miles with black which is
surprising because he's known as a
creative player but check his games out
because they're fascinating all right so
this was a little detour
he takes d5 C 2 XV v 9 f 3 9 6 C 3 now
if you're adventurous you could even try
Knight e5 which was used by Carlsen to
be drive I think in a rapid game many
times I think and it's okay it's
playable nothing special so don't expect
advantages c3 Bishop f5 and basically
white is playing a reversed
kind of yeah reverse kind of Cambridge
Springs structure and calls bad
structures Bishop f5 Bishop e2 a six now
a six now is a little bit unnecessary
knight c6 castles east six would be very
normal with equal positions it sixes
defending against some phantom that
doesn't exist anymore because white is
not really trying to play Bishop b5 and
anytime soon day six Castle might see
692 a very fine plan and good way of
developing in these caused bottle
structures it's coming around with the
night with 92 rook e1 not f1 as it
happens in this game as well Bishop d6 9
f 1 8 6 9 g3 bishop g6 now bishop g6 is
very normal in the mainline the one that
I showed here
Bishop g6 but would everyone play Bishop
g6 in this position anyone would suggest
a different move or you guys all agree
on that Bishop g6 is best
Bishop g4 yeah with the idea of
exchanging off denied right I presume
and
to be honest in these semi closed
positions the Knights are worth a heck
of a lot more than in open positions
they're actually more valuable so just
giving away this bishop for the night
there's not a bit of bad exchange Bishop
g4 is one option what are their options
this might have I mean black has in this
position
ninety-seven mm-hmm or Bishop age seven
how about that move a very very classy
move hiding away talking it away safe
into a safe place away from these nasty
Knights Bishop g6 9h for Bishop h7
Bishop d3 and I really like this way the
way why plays because white gives and
uses this extra temple that black gives
him for free
Bishop d3 intakes d3 b5 and Y is b5 a
little bit suspicious in this position
what's wrong in this position with the
b5 move yeah yeah black is ignoring the
threats and also when your opponent's is
attacking it's a good idea to castle so
Castle was kind of warranted and black
would be fine in this position I would
say it's roughly equal maybe slight
slight bit better for white in this
position what would white aim to do what
is the pivotal square in this position
what does white want to achieve as an
outpost for his knight
well f5 is not viable now because they
take the knight h5 maybe maybe but
there's one one squared that controls
all all just like in the Lord of the
Rings movies this is yes exactly the e5
square controls all whoever gets that
wins the game
so Knight f3 is a good move Queen c7
Queen e2 and I'd be even inclined to
play Knight d7 just not to give you this
he 5 squared and the fight will revolve
around this e5 square and whoever gets
it wins the game
but b5 was played which wasn't good
Knight f5 castles
yes and why played night takes h6 but is
that the only option in this position
what other options does white have in
this position because whenever you have
sacrificial ideas there might be other
solutions and you could use them and
they might be even better than your
first thoughts that's why it's worth
thinking about it
so yeah we see that I decided to take on
eight six which doesn't mean it's bad
but are there some other options here
for white what was your first mm-hmm
not F where
yeah we're green f3 and then it's a nice
pressure although let's be careful with
this 9 on h4 they can get easily trapped
but we're looking for ideas that
actually facilitates White's attack
apart from 90 X 86
maybe graduates
in fact I heard the suggestion nine
things ji-sun exactly that's the other
option this position now black needs to
take second bishop yes
takes and now there's a very very nice
sacrifice and it's a very tall like
sacrifice actual 9f5
just take yes rook takes c6 and this is
the truth I like sacrifice known from
the game tall portage where he
sacrificed his whole rook on e6 now if
this rook on e6 is taboo because F takes
and it's just mate and rook g8 is an
option but would be easily punished
how can Knight f5 what is another
solution it's actually two solutions
here we're kept six then the Queen takes
ya route takes on d6 and there's no way
you can take it back because Knight have
five check and I take your queen so
Knight takes h6 is an inspired sacrifice
and I'm not saying it's wrong but there
was this other option playing like tall
and actually tall is again all the hype
as offer zero is doing his best it's
best to emulate the style of tall which
is obviously a tough task because he was
a true genius
come again yeah King h8 yeah yeah I mean
you can play Bishop b5 and you will have
bishop rookies rookies reboot gage 3
yeah yeah there's a lot of things to
calculate or rookie 3 is an idea to go
with drover so not saying it's over but
it's something to consider 9 8 6 GT x86
Bishop takes aged six very nice
sacrifice what already has two pawns
plus the attack yeah
and rookie six still working correct
tonight
efore was played but bam rookie four D
takes Queen takes e4 hoof yeah clean up
six okay Green f6
yeah peen if 6 is nice but the problem
is that they take take take sniff takes
stick I know you take on age to take
sticks but if I count well and I don't
count that badly here's one two three
four five six against four and I call
the winner white yeah seems correct 997
Queen g4 going for the maiden that's the
right thing to do
96 96 and the problem here with black
that you're not just getting mated
you're losing all the material you had
at five Queen age 5 f6 Bishop g5 ship
takes h2 whoa ok King King takes h2 is
fine as well I think I don't see problem
with it there's a check but I'll just
move and I don't see a reason why why it
should be depressed yeah it's just just
great just great for white king of 1787
there's plenty of moves winning here and
oh that Queen sacrifice seems dubious
yeah but by this point white is just
totally winning any movies winning like
Queen of sinks is also win again Queen
f6 stakes and I just wrapped it up
there's a nice game although black if
black would have castled and that's what
I advise you to do whichever level you
are if you're a super GM watching this
please castle first and look around
because I don't want to see you get made
and in 15 moves so that's why you
shouldn't play the neither off all the
time sometimes you can play the ruler
pests okay that's all for you super GM
guys
let's see this game it's Tony
playing the black all right let's switch
the colors efore c5 yes speaking of
Sicilian its back c3
well not the most exciting but still a
viable option knight c6 96 is normal but
I think d5 is fine here
and if you're an aggressive player and
you like the style of MVL you play a
knight f6 v 595 and play some cheeky
chess d4 takes takes d6 and counter
attacking chances it's roughly equal
positions with a lot of dynamism
involved so it's fun knight c6 d 3 d3 is
Timothy 4 should have been played g6 yay
close Sicilian Bishop F well now Bishop
f4 is a bit suspect I'd say G 3 is
better Bishop g7 Bishop g2 d6 and the
classical way is Knight f3 but if you
have the option f4 is interesting
tonight f6 Knight f3
what has some extra space that he could
use yeah
Bishop g7 h 3 d6 g4 that's that's too
brave for me g4 is not great Knight f6
Bishop g2 d5 good move if your opponent
gives you the chance grab some more
space
Bishop g3 castles 92 d5 and this is kind
of reversed Kings Indian position where
Y has a terrible structure on like black
who has a totally fine structure
maybe three okay nightie to would we
warn to them it's still a five but I'd
prefer black night be 3d 2x c4 Knight c5
e 63 game d3 green d7 94
okay Knight takes e4 takes f5
well f5 is okay but what other options
we have what could be playing this
position
rook d8 yeah it's a good idea
stopping quite from castling long what
else could we play in this position
sure page six yeah there's some very
very simple moves we could do
any ideas what normal moves we could
make in this position yeah we should be
sick Bishop eight-six is it's not too
good because it says that this move is
either super or it's a little bit
suspicious
because if you have enough pressure on
this diagonal it's worth losing your
Tempe but if it's not that important
just develop your pieces there's no need
to rush you're just better anyways
that's why I'm a bit vary with the f5
move because now white will get to give
some checks when there was no need to
give some false hopes for white
Derbyshire p6 opponent would realize
that yeah I'm worse and after rook da
den f5 why would still be in big trouble
without any extra checks that he'd
hidden didn't Reserve didn't deserve
takes Bishop f5 in fact I prefer G takes
just to push the pawns although we can
already feel why we wanted Bishop e6
because there's already a check and why
it might have a time to actually
reorganize should buy five Green e3 e4
castles
and now the situation is not as clear as
before mine already has a good bishop on
g3 that he didn't have before it was
just awful there but as we play d4 the
bishop just activated so actually black
dropped a little bit of the advantage
here so how could we continue here with
black apart from the move that was
actually played b5 it would still not
meet 95 yes I like that move also
heading towards d3 92 will defend our
queen first because we don't want to run
into this nasty little trick of rook
takes d3 take some bye-bye
so 95 would have been a good move not
yeah a night c4 NEX is also a good idea
so rook c8 it's not necessarily a bad
move because even in many dragon
positions black does sacrifice the rook
for the active black squared Bishop
position is kind of similar to that
Bishop d6 Queen e6 takes King takes f8
and if we come back to the game the
Marshall game we looked at what's
similar to the Marshall game and this
one
I mean the night back on yeah
yeah yeah exactly so just like in a
Marshall as you pointed out what is
lagging in development and also those
beautiful bishops on g7 + f5 mostly the
g7 the f5 is useful though because it
puts some defensive effort on e4
kimby one between c4 92 and 94 I like
this move some heavy tactics going on
because if C takes then it's goodbye in
two moves okay let's take with the
bishop I prefer bishop mates so what is
in kind of a danger although Knights see
one would be kind of annoying like does
have pressure here though with 95 for
example with ideas of Knight takes
series let's say Queen e2 I'd strongly
consider taking here and winning the
game yeah I'd like this I like this with
black this is pretty good so even though
night c1 would be a good defensive idea
after Knight d5 black still has big play
Queen Queen takes e - Wow eat
green sacrifices everywhere III check
King B - thanks can get you three nights
C to check hmm yeah rook c5 that's just
what I was thinking
and that rook k5 seems to be more king a
fourth yeah I'm no offer zero but I
wouldn't want to be white this looks
suspicious i toy with ideas of knights
see - I don't see a clear win but Knight
see - Queen takes Bishop takes ho the
rook arrives again the 8th King e7
Bishop c6 that's a bit desperate
Eric d5 seems better
but obviously the problem is takes takes
an e2 and game over too many pieces ship
c6 ok five takes takes yeah let's
promote thanks and B promotes rook takes
c3 and now black wraps it up okay with
quite a few moves but he does when
checks everywhere a5 takes in b5 check
and slowly but surely black won the game
that's a very nice Queen sacrifice
actually and I like this game
Queen sacrifices are good if you can and
it works if you feel there's a huge
attack there try it it's fun all right
this will be it this is this was the
viewers choice and thank you for
watching
[Music]